the bench is gone
but not the threat this is where a
former russian spy
and his daughter collapsed victims of a
nerve agent poisoning blamed on russia
three years on could mi5 stop another
salisbury style attack
i think we have entered the same realm
that we are in with our
counter-terrorism colleagues which is
that we do absolutely everything we can
to stop any events from taking place in
the uk which are damaging
the uk population or property but there
are no
absolute guarantees i cannot say for
certain
that we are safe this is the first time
counterintelligence officers from the
security service have given an interview
a move authorized by mi5's
director-general
tom and kate spoke off-camera to protect
their identities
so these are re-enactments kate said the
mission of the military intelligence
unit
accused of the poisonings is centered on
eliminating russia's enemies abroad and
destabilizing the west
effectively a deniable group of
individuals or at least
i assume their intention was to be
deniable
but to conduct what is pretty dirty work
on behalf of the russian state russia
denies
any involvement in the attack on sergey
and julius gripal
but the then head of the hospital that
treated them
revealed fears of a second attempt on
their lives
we were of course worried whether
someone might want to come back and
finish off the job
and we didn't know for sure whether
somebody would
try and uh and
kill them so we had to be very careful
to ensure
security in the intensive care unit
it's not just the scrupals at risk mi5
has bolstered protection for other
people who might be targeted
we know that the russian state continues
to take an interest in people here
who we deem to be at risk and that's
not a passive interest it's got an
active interest
tom told me the attack here in salisbury
accelerated changes that were already
underway
across the intelligence community to
deal with the russia threat
this includes with mi5 mi6
and gchq pulling their resources
into a single russia mission in much the
same way
as they work together to counter the
threat from terrorism
britain kicked out almost two dozen
russian spies in response to salisbury
moscow apparently keen to rebuild its
team here
we work really hard on preventing them
from doing that
have we been entirely successful time
will tell
russia deemed and evolving though not a
worsening danger
debra haynes sky news